would you say that like a lot of the
females are like
emotion guided
so like to different likes situations
and stuff
it just depends on the situation
yeah it just depends on the situation
because if it's a situation where it's
not affecting me mentally then we have a
problem
whereas like if i'm if i'm okay with it
and i can deal with it then i'm all
right type thing because normally um
because normally the like it's been i
don't know where it's been said but like
like when it's like hard decisions not
necessarily like buying a house but like
men tend to be more saints and like you
know and like more composed and whereas
like women are like more like
but if the emotion is maybe we just
think that's what we're going to go all
the stuff as well
like not just the decision like what
else could affect the decision like what
more is there to it like you could buy a
house but i'm thinking like is the train
station there like can i get to college
can i go to work
there's just so much more to the
decision
i feel like
right yeah that's a bit generalizing
though i feel like yeah like and any man
could think like that as well any woman
so it's like
yeah hear what you're saying
let's answer your question we all
we are we naturally or at least we
develop
responding with emotion and then there
are those of us who develop trying to
suppress that and responding with logic
but majority of the time we all respond
at least we i would say we respond with
emotion first
in
most situations i think everyone like
male to female sustain yeah 100 oh i
don't women are chemically different
every single day
like depending on where we're at in our
cycle like before or before that's like
why we get super irritable before a
period
so i think men like naturally or more
he's had enough
like you don't understand
second day that
first day is like the come on is cool
the second day the second day oh my god
how have you been around jesus christ
like i just think that like women come
more from a place like and i'm a pretty
logical girl but like yeah i feel like
even i feel like the most logical girls
we acknowledge that we're emotional like
we're emotional beings and we kind of
look to men to be more logical
you know you've never noticed a
difference in the emotions between men
and women during the time of the month
women have like more mood swings
just in general like women because you
said you think it's equal and i'm just
shocked because no i meant i feel like
we equally in situations
equally
would naturally respond emotionally not
all the time but i feel like it's i feel
like i think you're an emotional male 1
yeah definitely
as in being in touch with my emotions
yeah yeah 100 yeah i'm not
stone cold
sometimes it's so especially like
relationships it's so hard to
communicate with you guys and come to an
agreement because
y'all don't want to be vulnerable i'm
not talking like oh we're talking
generally
so it makes it harder
like we'll we'll have a whole we'll talk
for like 30 minutes and you'll be like
cool why
and i'm sat here explaining to you why
yeah i don't know
i know you're thinking more than you're
saying you have to put it on the table
nah but you know what it is you gotta
you gotta understand right when you're
in a relationship with like
uh together right and let's say you you
have a disagreement about it right a man
will only go to like a certain level we
will go and we'll tell you the logic
side of it will tell you the facts and
stuff like that your emotions take over
to a point where we just want to leave
we just don't want to continue with the
conversation because like we're not no
man has ever won an argument with a
woman like
if he's one no but like you know but you
know i mean that you know i mean that
you know what i mean it's like no matter
no matter if you think you won you
haven't won you know i'm trying to say
like i guess like for example the way i
feel if like if i've had an argument ago
it's like
i'll be done it's not about winning the
argument it's about coming to an
agreement either you agree to disagree
or come to an agreement if you're wrong
if you're wrong
but the thing is
in a healthy relationship we don't argue
to win
but but the thing is like
you say you want emotional availability
but women aren't attracted to that
always
when that guy shows a vulnerability yeah
girls think oh they want a guy who like
cares but when it when they show a bit
of like sensitivity and stuff then they
get turned off like they're like they
don't like that but who said that then
like
they've studied this like when men
when men cry there's been multiple
studies that say when megan
when men cry when men cry in front of
women the woman loses respect for him
and it's not and and i would be in you
know what here's have you ever dated an
[ __ ]
go that's what i mean
wait so you dated an [ __ ] right so
you're attracted you're not attracted to
emotional availability that's what i
wanted i wanted someone to be no but no
you didn't because that's who you were
sleeping with
that's what you think you want but it's
not what you actually want go ahead yeah
like go girls yeah
they like they like bad boys like when
our guys they say oh they want a nice
guy does all of this like and then when
that guy comes around they're like oh
whatever then they're like well
personally what's that
it's literally it's literally you know
what it is it's literally it's literally
the
guy comes around like you said yeah it's
like they look they took one look at him
they give him like
one two maybe three dates if you're
lucky yeah but if you show that that
you're there for her like emotional
stuff like that that's not attractive to
the woman the woman the woman and i've
said it's an older podcast me i'm a very
emotional person like i feel like if you
can now connect to me on that level then
i'm good because clear communication and
expressing yourself to me
allows me to express me to you type
thing i don't feel like
not like at the start when you're first
like that and that's like deep like when
you're in when you've known each other
for a couple years maybe
not a couple years exactly like this
i can have an emotional like connection
with someone in a week yeah i feel like
i need to have that conversation with
you can you open up exactly because are
you able to open up because a lot of men
they get taught from their mothers and
family to not be emotional to not talk
about their emotions to be a man to be
strong you know all of that so that's
why i feel like a lot of men also have
problems communicating their feelings
because they're not used to it how long
do you guys think that you should be
seeing a girl before you like start to
open up emotionally i think i should do
it as little as possible to be honest
because because it's bad advice like you
know i'm telling you like i think you
guys come at it with like a good a good
heart
but like
you're chemically less attracted to men
that are vulnerable
because like
and it's not it's not a nice reality but
this is this is how i know it every time
i ask girls have you dated an [ __ ]
they always say yes
they always say yes
that a second because you said like why
would you keep on sleeping with that
person i think for a couple weeks you
still have that hope that he might open
up someday but you end up leaving you do
but i don't that's the reason you're not
in a relationship with that [ __ ]
you're just dating him well did he want
to be in a relationship the [ __ ]
probably not no comment yeah that's
that's what i'm saying but it's always
really good
and this is this is what i'm saying like
like in the reason the reason there's
like biological reasons that we feel the
way we feel and we can't just undo them
so the reason is because the same traits
that make the guy the hero also make him
the villain
so like like the guy that's the
protector provider like he he he has to
be you know aggressive on some level he
has to be able able to protect you
and emotionally in control you don't see
superman crying
like
like in a movie you see hulk when he
like just goes all the way back to human
just for his girl
not necessarily crying crying yeah but
he was he was better when he was green
hulk hulk found his hulk found his piece
so